one Lord day until WWDC it is so so
close I can almost smell the new I was
gonna say apples products but I guess
Apple software because again it is a
Developers Conference so a lot of the
things that they're gonna be announcing
it has to do with software updates so
I've already made a video talking about
some of the iOS 13 rumors but some of
the other things that we are predicting
that will be announced WDC is an updated
version of mac OS which would be 10.15
updates to TV OS and of course watch OS
the watch OS update is something that
I'm really excited about like I love my
Apple watch so much I've talked about it
in the past it has been just one of my
most favorite devices of course other
than my iPhone but I use it so much I
don't think I've really taken it off
since I was like four years and to prove
it my body has conformed to my Apple
watch I am my watch here on that rumors
they're talking about some of the new
health applications that are the works
one of which is a DOS app it's for pill
reminders a cycles app for tracking your
menstrual cycles this is something that
I'm excited about
ladies I think that you will be excited
about it as well I'd like to have like a
countdown but it's like five days of
freedom four days of freedom three days
until you're miserable today is gonna
suck tomorrow is gonna be awful welcome
to your week of misery I'd be really
great if it would send you like presents
or something in the mail like a pack of
tampons I don't know
I will plans to add a calculator app of
voice memos app an app for listening to
audiobooks plus an emoji me emoji
stickers all on your wrist new watch
faces including gradient that makes a
gradient out of color the user chooses
two new extra-large watch faces showing
jumbo numbers I really like that because
if you do have difficulty seeing or if
you don't have your contacts in or
something like that you may be able to
see it a little bit better another thing
that's a big highlight for the watch OS
is that the app watch will be getting
its own App Store so much like there's
an iOS app store there's a Mac OS app
store an Apple watch app store if I want
to easily download install apps and buy
apps so I think that's gonna be kind of
interesting because that's also gonna
open up a whole nother world of app
developers that would be another revenue
stream obviously you can still have a
velar japs' now but having its own
dedicated app store
I feel like we'll just have more
visibility to the apps that are
available so the app store will then be
available right on your wrist you can
download and install apps right from
here so you won't need your phones again
I already talked about some of the iOS
13 updates but if you haven't seen that
video I'll put a link in the description
and an annotation where you can go watch
that entire thing but basically the
highlight for me on iOS 13 is going to
be having a dedicated dork mode the
updates to the files app which is
desperately needed find my friends app
the messages the mail they'll be all
kinds of other updates of course along
with some speed updates hopefully
improved battery life so it's always
something that is very very important
and I will never forget that update from
11:00 to 12:00 was so incredibly
significant there were so many issues
with 11 that iOS 12 was like a brand-new
freaking phone
I don't think 13 will be that much of an
upgrade because 12 already works pretty
well but I am definitely looking forward
to everything as they do announce Mac OS
10 15 something else that I'm looking
forward to even though I'm one of those
people that I wait a very long time and
to update my OS is on my max I'll
usually update it on a secondary device
that I don't edit on I'm always so
concerned with the compatibility of
Final Cut and the updates so usually
that's something that takes precedent
over an updated OS it looks like Apple
is planning to introduce new music
podcasts and books apps in OS 10 15 they
will be available alongside a new TV app
designed for the Mac which is kind of
also exciting so you'll be able to
download the Apple TV app on your Mac do
a little to watch all of that TV content
directly on here this is well to some
other new features include support for
an iPad as an external display this is I
mmm I'm into this especially because I
travel so much I usually almost always
have my iPad Pro with me so they're able
to use that as a secondary display
whether I'm just using it for email or
kind of like a second window over Final
Cut that's gonna be so cool dude Mac bro
I hope this happens I mean I'm not gonna
hold my breath because if I do I might
pass out I might die and I don't want a
guy before wEDC happens but it says that
rumor suggests Apple is considering
previewing the redesign Mac pearl
oh look at that that's interesting look
how thin that is what is that well it's
got a tip or something that knock that
off your desk so fast
you're gonna blink and that thing's
gonna fall over not realistic but this
is cool I kind of like that it's kind of
liking this slimmed down version of the
old school towers that trash can back
definitely should have saved my money so
those have been some of the things that
I've read online that people are
expecting that will be at WWDC
I think for me I'm really looking
forward to seeing if we're gonna have
any type of updates on the home pod
because I love my home pod I use my home
pod so much I walk around my house
talking to Siri all day like she's a
friend
I mean sometimes she doesn't answer me
or she does answer me and doesn't answer
the right questions sometimes doesn't
even listen to me at all
speaking of Siri can we just talk about
how just frustratingly non-cooperative
she is sometimes I ask her a question
like okay what is Oprah's middle name
[Music]
again
I found Orpah and Gail okay what was I
saying oh I was trying to show you that
sometimes Siri doesn't listen to me but
that was not a good demo either you guys
have used Siri long enough you know what
I'm talking about so I just think that
the overall database and knowledge and
just the AI of Siri needs to step it up
significantly
so that is something that I think that
if they make any mention of that it'll
be WDC you will hear applauds you will
see me standing up flapping my hands
like a seal
[Music]
I'm also hoping for some new an emoji
characters maybe an updated an emoji
accessories list potentially something
where you can go in and buy things for
your Mii emoji I would do it I'm sure
many of you would do microtransactions
it's such a sucker
of course I'm hoping for some iPhone
updates but again this is a software
developers conference so we probably
won't get much on hardware although I
will cross my fingers and hope for the
best which is why I also hope that they
will announce something regarding the
Mac Pro maybe it's just a little hint of
something I don't know maybe a hint of a
new home pod like a home pod with the
screen or like a mini home pod I don't
know I don't care I want all of it okay
I'm gonna calm down because it's getting
a little bit excited I mean Chuco pack
and I will see you guys at WWDC it's
here it's almost here it's not here yet
but it will be depending upon how fast I
edit this video okay I'd love to know
from you guys what are some things that
you're looking forward to what are some
of the predictions that I mentioned that
you think will be real like most of them
actually will be real or not that
far-fetched but I will see you guys
again WDC don't forget to subscribe hit
the bell follow me on twitter follow me
on instagram follow me on freakin
tik-tok I joined tick tock recently not
sponsored joined in on my own accord
okay I'm gonna go edit this video I
don't know I'm just getting so excited
I'm getting so excited I gotta go I
gotta go bye
[Music]
[Applause]